for the invitation it looks to be a
great uh series a great Workshop this
week
particularly so I find this a very
frustrating time in population genetics
evolutionary genetics because we have a
huge amount of data in principle we have
the possibility of getting complete
sequences of every individual in a
population and there's clearly a lot of
information about both demography
demographic history and about selection
locked up in that
data um and we have a very simple
elegant kind of theoretical framework at
least for the neutral case where we have
the ancestral recombination graph
describing the coalesence and re
combination of lineages genomes as we go
backwards in time and in principle we
should just be able to put together this
this very fine theoretical framework
with the mass of data and answer all
kinds of questions but it's kind of a
little bit embarrassing actually that I
don't think we've really answered the
basic questions that we started out with
even you know 50 years ago uh what
maintains variation how many low SI
selected what's the distribution of
effects on quantitative frea and so on
and so forth
and and we're using really very very
crude methods for data analysis which
are clearly you know throwing away a lot
of the information that we have so at
the simplest level we have you know just
look the idea of looking
at individual Snips one by one so if we
had a sample of genomes from a single
population we could just count the site
frequency spectrum the numbers of copies
of a particular variant at a particular
site and that will tell us a lot and we
can treat the site frequency spectrum
across the whole genome but that throws
away any information about associations
between markers between Snips we could
divide the genome up in a rather
arbitrary way into blocks which we
imagine and not recombining too much and
we could try to estimate the geneal
ology connecting I suppose I WR like
that the genealogy connecting the
particular set of blocks there but again
that's a rather arbitrary procedure and
it's again throwing away any information
about uh re combination about linkage
disequilibrium and of course there are
all sorts of methods out there but all
of them are partial ways of looking at
the data and somewhat arbitrary and we'd
like in principle to be able to
calculate the probability of observing
the set of mutations that we see along a
linear genome um given the ancestral
recombination graph which is at the
moment a very distant
um so what I'm going to do is talk about
uh really a very simple straightforward
very general method for uh calculating
the probability of a genealogy at one or
a number of Loi possibly in a structured
population and this is work that I've
been doing with Conrad lza from
Edinburgh who I hope is here and say to
answer yes difficult questions because
I'll also rather briefly mention um
applications that Conor has been making
two various data sets of this this
approach the idea of calculating exact
like because for admittedly rather small
data sets we can manage you know three
four five genomes maybe but um but
genomewide and then what I'll
concentrate on at the end of the talk is
uh generalization of this this Machinery
really for calculating the The Joint
probability of genealogies and re
combination events along a continuous
linear genome and
I have to admit at this stage that I
haven't quite been able to get to the
last sentence of the abstract so don't
read the abstract in the book but there
were going to be interesting
applications I'll outline this as
exercises for the reader at the end um
I'm sure we will want something to do in
the in the other talks um the basic idea
though is that we should be able to use
information from the uh patterns of
change in genealogy along the genome um
using essentially recombination as a
clock uh to com to give us more
information about time scales about
rates of processes and actually to give
us a clock which applies over a much
wider range of time scales than mutation
can okay so mutations occur at a set
rate per site recombination of course
occurs at that reasons I guess which are
rather interesting but unclear
recombination occurs a similar rate per
site but of course if we look over
larger and larger ranges we can estimate
co-ancestry
over a whole range of time scales and
for example there very nice work by uh
grahe Coupe who I think has been
substituted here Graham's not here as
you know but he sent a substitute okay
good so it's nice work looking at the uh
at identifying individuals who share
ancestry at some time in the past on the
grounds that they share lengths of
genome which are identical by descent
and the longer the stretch identical by
the same the more recent the co-ancestry
and so you're using their Rec
combination rate as a clock to tell you
the time since coancestry and the idea
is generally that we should be able to
use much more effectively information
about patterns along the genome along a
linear continuous genome using as a
fundamental Mod The ancestral
combination graph okay so before I get
onto that uh start with the the basic
idea behind um behind all this which is
that we can describe a genealogy by the
lengths of the branches and so if we
have a set of three genes a BC I'll
denote the complete
set by
Omega and so now we have
here in this particular topology we have
four four internal branches described by
uh t a b t a TB TC that is the times of
the branches leading down to a certain
set of genes either one gene or in this
case
these two genes and in general we can
describe all the possible topologies by
listing a vector in this case of six
possible Branch lengths um which encode
both the shape and actual uh lengths of
this
genealogy
so so then we say that instead of
working with
the
the probability of observing a certain
set of Branch lengths we work with the
lass transform of that or the generating
function for that which is just given by
this expectation
okay and from that we can calculate
anything we want and in particular we
can calculate rather easily the
probability of observing a certain set
of mutations so we've transformed the
probability of a certain set of Branch
lengths to a function and it's a
function of a set of dummy variables
these omegas which correspond to the
branch length so for every Branch we
have a corresponding dummy variable
Omega and we generate this function and
we want to calculate things from that
for example we might want to calculate
the probability of seeing a certain
number of mutations on a particular
Branch call that KS the number on the
branch leading down to the set s of
genes and basically you can calculate
that just by
differentiating the generating function
a certain number of times by a number of
times equal to the number of
mutations and so we can calculate
observable quantities mutational
configurations you can calculate in the
same way the probability of seeing a
certain set of mutations a certain
number which
are
n so for
example this particular mutation is
shared by A and B so we will denote that
k a b this one is shared by a b and
c and so on we can calculate the
probability of seeing one of these one
of these and so on by differentiating
this generating function and that's
relatively easy to do as long as you
don't have too many mutations
okay is there a question yeah is there a
question yeah yeah I don't your
notation how you coding different
topologies here okay so that's the neat
thing that this single function codes
all of the topologies so this particular
case has constraints on the branch
lengths right which mean that t a is
some number T A and T BC are zero okay
and so on and then ta equals TB Etc but
there's also probability of another
topology which we have other constraints
and all of that translates basically
into this generating function which
actually is a a sum of terms and each
term could be identified with a certain
topology
okay okay
so so we want to be able to calculate
this and it turns out that there's a
very simple recursion for the generating
function which can be automated
in a rather straightforward
way and what we do is simply Trace back
from a certain configuration of genes
here we've got three separate genes we
Trace back to the next previous event
which is in this case is a coalesence
between a and
b and in this very simple example a
single population with three genes there
are three possible events we can
have uh a coalesence between each of
these three
pairs and we could generalize it we
could have multiple lowai for example we
might think of having the possibility of
Rec combination as well
so say we had two lowai we could
have let's
say samples where we took initially
three chromosomes at this Locus we have
a b and c labeling these alals x y and
Zed labeling these alals and so that we
have gen genomes which are ancestral to
a and X twoos have B and Y C and Zed and
as we Trace
back well maybe they're inherited
together and they coales together but
maybe there's a combination
event such that this lineage then traces
back to there so now as we go back we
can count a rate of two kinds of events
Rec combination events or coalesence
events and the recursion turns out to be
very simple it's just basically a sum
over the possible events a sum over the
generating functions for simpler
configurations in which these have
cessed for
example plus a sum over uh re
combination rates times the
configurations in which these lineages
here or this lineage here split into two
lineages one ancestral to C and the
other ancest to see okay so
we in this term simply summing over all
possible events as we go back in time
and then we divide by this term which is
related to the total rate of coalescence
which is just k2's two plus the total
rate of recombination plus a sum of
dummy variables corresponding
to these leads so these dummy variables
in this example would be w a plus WX
plus WB plus w y w c plus W Z so on that
is we sum over all the de variables
corresponding to these lengths of these
lineages okay and the reason for doing
that is that what we're doing as we go
back is simply adding an exponentially
distributed
time to each of these
lineages and this generating function
has the property that if we add an
dependent exponential variable we simply
multiply the generating function by the
corresponding uh function that pass
transform for that exponential
distribution so we have this very simple
recursion which as you can see could be
rather easily
automated for
Conant yes
well yes it is right but no I'm going I
did say it was General so it's quite
General it we'll get to that yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I should say so far it's
really been very very simple standard
coalescent scaling time relative to 2N
should have said that
so um this is the standard coalescent
but you can actually have a very very
broad view of what events are here I
included re combination but we could
also say that there are changes in
population structure there is a certain
rate going forwards in time at which
populations split okay
and there's a kind of neat trick which
says that if we
calculate yeah
the clear some
space if we calculate the
expectation
of of this this quantity we end up with
something
like ter involving e to minus Lambda T
where Lambda is the rate of population
splitting and if we then take the
inverse of this generating function
which includes this rate of splitting
treat this as a llast transform uh we
take the inverse llast transform we can
actually calculate explicitly the
generating function given a certain
event at a certain time in the past so
there's a way to go from a model in
which we include a uniform rate of
various events Rec combination
coalesence and possibly population
splitting or possibly the existence of a
bottleneck or something like this and
then we can take a rather simple inverse
transform with respect to the time of
the Bott time of the population split
and calculate the the actual probability
structure
culation I have a question is this dummy
variables that you mentioned the the
determinates are there the corresponding
to the lengths or or to the specific
three um okay
so yeah yeah so the the question was
what are these D variables so in general
if I just go
back
uh you probably can't actually read it
about but these are vectors so this is
the vector of D
variables do product with the vector of
Branch length so there's a w variable
for each branch length so you have
complete information about the whole
Branch
structure if you're only caring about
say the length of the
genealogy then you just set all of these
to the same value all the omegas to the
same value and then you get a single
function of a single variable Omega
which gives you the generating function
for the length of the genealogy but
there are many ways of writing this uh
for different length I mean I can I can
split the length in different ways right
I don't think it's well defined this way
no I think I mean you have a genealogy
like this so if you tell me or well if
you know what these Fran links are then
that gives you all the observable
information about this genealogy
condition on this is well defined yeah
but in general for this specific three
structure maybe I'm missing something
yeah well and then you you also have the
possibilities of other tree structures
but those simply have a different
relationship amongst these Branch
lengths so here you know that it's this
topology because um T BC and T AC are
zero okay so that's you imagine a
distribution over all possible
genealogies and there'll be a set
there'll be a distribution for this
topology this topology this topology and
each of those depends on a smaller
number of branch
but in aggregate there's a complete
joint distribution of Branch LS which
covers all the toies okay
anyway for what the dummy variables are
I mean intuitively I like to think of
them as rates but yeah I mean I I know
that's that's you know not exactly yes I
don't know I've always thought of them
as just W
variable you know there a procedure
maybe you have better intuition for
Trans because you did physics properly
right so you can you can see the L
transform in your head but yeah
okay
so so I'm not actually going to say very
much about this population structure
issue about structured populations where
we have migration we have splitting and
populations we have bottlenecks and this
kind of thing but just to say the method
does apply to that I'll be focusing
later on on the issue of recombination
and extending this from discrete lo I
with discrete recombination rates to a
linear but before doing that before
running out of time I'll just briefly
mention um
um work that con has been doing
to apply this scheme to some data sets
uh one on G wasps which are kind of nice
to work with because they're
haplodiploid so you look at male you've
got haid genome is convenient and this
particular paper was based on five ghl
wasps five male ghl wasps one from uh
Iran and two from Central Europe two
from Western Europe the data was reduced
down to two replicate data sets of
triplets East Central
West based on two almost different uh
sets of three three
Gs and the question was can we
distinguish different models of
population history in which we have
different schemes for population
separation different schemes for ad
mixture between those
populations and a cut a long story short
you can using this scheme estimate uh
the best supported model and estimate
the degree of AD mixture between them so
the best suppored model in this case is
that the Eastern population split from a
central population and then further back
in time had split from the Western
population and there was evidence of a
recent admixture event from East out the
West okay and you can estimate actually
rather precisely the times of these
various events and the proportion of AD
mixture the dotted lines and solid lines
here correspond to the two replicate
data sets which correspond just to
different flies chosen from more or less
the same
populations and this was based on about
2,000 blocks of genome arbitrarily
defined to be 2 KB at least long and to
be well separated so you have complete
genome data then filter that clean it up
and get well aligned blocks which are
reasonably well
separated but actually the results are
rather robust to uh to the numbers of or
to the sizes of blocks that you
choose um so what what I should say that
the scheme is is based on a method which
is very nicely scalable to large data
sets so the idea is that for a small
sequence block with not too many
mutations in it you can tabulate all all
the possible mutational configurations
and calculate their probability
okay and obviously you can't do that for
an indefinitely large number of
mutations because that involves
differentiating this funny function many
many times and the computer
collapses but you can calculate the
probability that there are not one two
three many of each kind of mutation and
tabulate a big table of all the possible
combinations of those up to some upper
limit and then you simply multiply the
light fields acoss all the LOI so
there's really no limit to the number of
Loi you you can have the limit is in the
number of configurations you have to do
the calculations for
okay so just to mention a second
analysis which Conrad has done with
Laurel France who unfortunately supposed
to be here but can't be here I had to
leave early um this is on the the Neal
data set in fact what they're aiming to
do is to do a similar analysis for a
much more interesting situation with
pigs in uh in Indonesia I think but uh
they they're warming up with the nandal
data set and they basically use the same
method using this idea of dividing the
genome into short blocks with small
number of variants and really trying to
analyze the data more efficiently than
simply with the abababa D statistic
which simply compares the numbers of two
different kinds of snip Snips
corresponding to two different
discordant genealogies they go beyond
that by asking about the complete
distribution of all the different
mutations that you can get in short
blocks and by doing that they definitely
reject the hypothesis of ancestral
structure and estimate a rate of
admixture between the nandal and the
European population of you know a few
percent okay so it's given the same kind
of picture as uh the D statistic does
but it's doing it much more accurately
and the accuracy seems actually rather
surprisingly to us to be quite robust
your choice of block size to the
presence of a combination which actually
has been ignored here yeah so the the
mixture proportions are discrepant with
the current estimates of mixture
proportions so
um is maybe fine what reg the you
looking at
uh
the so you're using the the whole lot so
there's a discrepancy that's fine okay
so yeah so what what's the current ES
I think we'd be very surprised based on
our last paper if it was more than I me
most the estimates were under 2% with
standard errors that would exclude
numbers more than 2.5% right and is that
based on D or it's based on something
like a d statistic basically the
numerators of the D
statistic an F4 statistic ratio yeah we
probably talk later about that because
it's I mean or rather conr talk later
about it but it's um I mean one of the
issues of course is that you're getting
extra information here from Singletons
and there's a lot of error in the
undertale Singleton because all the the
error so there's some issue about how
you clean up you're using Rich
information that was not used there so
it's interesting anyway yeah I mean
maybe if there is a discrepancy it
points to Something Real that some other
model is appropriate not the models
we're looking
at okay so how does the sorry another
question how does the approach related
relate to other methods that have been
used to do similar things like um dhong
yangs or method um
uh
mcmc okay so the mcmc methods as I
understand it are really very hard to
scale up to very very large numers of Lo
because you have an extra computational
cost for every lock us you add um and so
actually that it's very impressive that
they work with the number of Loi they do
but it's clearly scales much more slowly
than than this does okay um it's quite
close to things that Zang Yang's done
and in fact there have been calculations
around also Asar hobal has done
calculations of exact likelihoods and
and use these kinds of methods and I
think what what I'm most interested in
is that it's a very general method that
allows you to do the calculations in an
automatic way for complicated models you
know if you try and do it by hand you
kind of go mad after you know very short
time but here at least the computer is
driven mad after a slightly longer
time anyway okay so I'll just as I've
not too much time when when do I end is
that got 10 minutes or
15 minutes oh I can do the whole
G okay so so this is all still very crw
because these analyses are sort of
taking a continuous sequence and Cho
arbitrarily chopping it up into bits
that you hope aren't recombining too
much you know which you know actually
can't exactly be true so what we'd like
to do would be to have a way of
generating probabilities for a truly
continuous genome and the situation we
have then is that we have this long line
we choose a random point on the genome
and let's work out in One Direction okay
it's easy to see how you generalize it
to two directions work out in One
Direction at some point there will be a
recombination event that changes the
genealogy so let's suppose that we
actually have three sample
genomes and at the focal point there is
a
particular genealogy let's say like that
and so this is purple region
and then we move out and at some point
there's a re combination event somewhere
in this
genealogy let's say
there and a coalesence back
there so that the topology is the same
in this example but the coalesence time
between these two is slightly shorter
okay and so we now have a region with a
slightly different genealogy
here and then we carry on and we have
now maybe a accommodation
event
so
here so we might have another
combination of in there so that now this
red
genealogy I've drawn this
right looks like this
okay so what we really want is a joint
distribution of genealogies which are
being described by these vectors of
Branch
lengths and locations of combination
events
actually what we work with are the sizes
of these
intervals and so we want
to find some kind of generating function
for the joint distribution of
genealogies along the genome and
positions at which recombination events
change the genealogy
okay and there's a list
of subtleties which I put here which are
probably
yeah well just to indicate really that
there there are there's some tricky
parts to this it comes up with a robly
simple formula but there's some tricky
issues to deal
with the basic reason we can we can work
with it is that the distribution of
these distances here are closely related
to the lengths of the corresponding
genealogy because basically a
recombination event can occur if we talk
about this first recombination event
that recombination event can occur
anywhere on the focal genealogy on the
first genealogy and the probability that
it occurs as we move along has rate L
where L is the length total Branch
length of the first
genealogy and then as we move on we now
have this green genealogy we can now get
a Rec combination event which occurred
here and again that's distributed over
the genealogy but now we actually have
potentially we have actually more
branches on which it can occur it's
slightly tricky I won't go into all the
details but basically as we extend the
ancestral accomodation
graph the recombination events can occur
anywhere on the genealogies proximal to
this so that if we go out to say
Ln here a Rec combination event could
occur and could change the gene anywhere
proximal to that but the total length of
the branches is not just the sum of all
those lengths because most of the
branches go inside so we defined
something called lstar which is the
length of branches on which a
significant recombination can occur
basically and the basic point is that
recombination in non-ancestral material
can be important so that if we had for
example a situation
where a certain lineage was carrying a
block here ancestral to a and another
block also ancestral to to that same
genome then a recombination event here
even though it's not in ancestral
material will produce two lineages and
those will then behave differently if we
start thinking about coalesence with
some other lineage basically there's
twice the rate of coalesence of a
lineage with two recombined lineages
than with a single lineage so the
precise probability ities do depend on
kind of internal structure depend on
events that occur actually anywhere in
quite in a longer and longer stretch of
J another
complication is that we can have rather
annoyingly a combination events that
coales back that produce lineage that
Coes is back onto the same lineage and
then we have two blocks as I defined it
but they have identical genealogies and
we just have to live with that at least
I haven't found a way way to produce a
simple recursion which guarantees that
these points are points where we have
distinct genealogies there's a small
probability that actually these happen
to be identical genealogies but that's
not too big an
issue a final point to mention is that
it
matters that we choose a focal point at
a particular location we throw down a
random Point here and we have a certain
length of block out to here but what we
find and it's sort of a little bit
puzzling at first is that the
distribution of lengths here is
different from this distribution is
different from this distribution there's
an assment issue the point is that if we
take a series of blocks defining
different genealogies along the genome
and then we throw down a random point
that random point will tend to land on a
long block which will also tend to have
a shallow coalescence time a recent
coalesence time and so the distribution
of coalescent SES at a randomly chosen
point tends to be uh okay it right tends
to be shallower than the distribution of
coalescence times at a randomly chosen
block therefore as we work out from a
random
location we find actually that the
blocks get shorter
okay
so I'll just skip quickly through the
case of two blocks and the basic idea is
very simple that the probability The
Joint probability of the uh Branch
lengths T and T1 and the location of the
recombination events K and K just depend
on in this simple case the lengths of
the
genealogies and we follow a generating
function defined in this way not quite
the generating function of this joint
distribution very close to it and we can
derive a recursion which looks actually
very similar to the one before for a
discrete Loi in which we have a
denominator
ah let's put the parenthesis in yeah we
have a denominator now it's correct uh
in which we have the total rate of
coalescence the rates of re combination
K being the number of lineages that can
recombine in the simple example but
these are now multiplied not by re
combination rates as before but by the
lengths of the intervals K and K1 these
are the intervals sizes of the blocks
basically and then on top we have a sum
over possible coalesence events possible
uh recombination events but we have
another uh trick that we have to keep
track of we have to have an index here
which says there is one recombination of
eight pending because if we've decided
we're going to follow these two blocks
separated by recombination event here
then once that recombination event has
occurred it can't occur again we're
restricting ourselves at the start of
the thing to looking at just two blocks
separated by one Rec combination event
and so once we have made the first
recombination event we now say we use P
not sorry this is combination event
happened we now go to P which is the
standard coalescent with no
recombination
okay
so well yeah so in this example we can
write down the generating functions the
generating
function here for two blocks and two
individuals that can only change by Rec
combination because if we allow them to
coales we then wouldn't be allowed to
have a recompilation everything would
have ended and yet we're saying we want
to have two genealogies separated at
lock as a and lock as B separated by a
recombination event so we only allow
recombination it can occur either uh
between B and B1 or between a and A1
once it's occurred we then go back to
the standard coalescent not which is
given by the expressions for standard
exponential distribution and so on so
it's a very simple expression here
but the result we get is actually
non-trivial we can calculate the for
example things like the distribution of
lengths of blocks sharing the same
genealogy and interestingly the
distribution of lengths of the first
block that is the position from a focal
point to the first Rec combination event
on the right is a very F tailed Koshi
type distribution which has a mean of
infinity so that's actually a bit
depressing from the point of view of
data analysis because it tells you that
if you land
on a random point you have a small
probability of having an extremely long
region uh which will share the same
genealogy implying there's going to be a
lot of sampling error a lot of error
depending on where exactly you land it's
a distribution of an infinite an
infinite
mean however the distribution of length
of the next block is better behaved it's
kind of complicated form but it has a
mean a 088 scaled relative to population
size and that's simply because of this
ascertainment issue the first block you
land on is likely to be longer maybe be
much longer than uh a typical
block and get that cut a long story
short we can extend this to actually get
a generating function for an arbitary
number of blocks for an arbitrary number
of genomes and we have to actually
track an index here which keeps count of
the number of recommendation limits
we've used up so we might have 10 blocks
10 recombination events say so then we
have a vector which ticks off as we go
through through the recursion that we've
had this recombination we've had this
recombination made and it's a nice
recursion because it's closed we simply
iterate and we get down to the answer
okay there's no uh there's nothing
complicated about
it and that means that we can automate
it so I hope this works we can define a
function which is only about that much
code it's pretty simple which say which
actually produces a set of equations
telling us what happens after one round
of the recur verion after one event
given a generating function for some
configuration s whatever that is might
be a configuration like
that then we iterate it and we express
it in terms of a linear combination of
other configurations and we keep going
using this fix Point function until we
end the
recursion
and so it's quick right
so uh it gets of course a lot slower if
you add more and more genes but you get
a function here which encodes the
topology which encodes all of the branch
lengths of the two
genealogies and go down
here it's fairly
short had a bigger screen um we can
simplify it by this operation simply
collapses all the D variables so we say
we only care about the lengths of the
first one the length of the second one
so this is actually the generating
function for the joint distribution l0
L1 the two lengths of these which
corresponds to the numbers of mutations
you would see in the first and second
genealogy um
so
back and I suppose we can check that
this integrates to
one this is unwise no it
doesn't oh well mathematics has broken
down that's a well let's ignore that it
does integrate to one on good days okay
so I've sort of run out of time but
basically you can do lots and lots of
calculations of things like the
probability there are no Snips in a
certain interval length x and you do
that by saying what's the chance that
the block is longer than the interval X
and there's no mutation then what's the
chance that there is one recombination
me with the interval and there's no
mutation in either of them Etc and for a
relatively low rate
of uh yeah so up here for mutation to
rec combination .5 that is re
combination twice as fast as mutation as
you go in from a calculation based on a
single block where you can put bounds on
the probability of seeing no mutation
per distance X to one block to two
blocks to three blocks and so on you
Converge on a good estimate of the
distribution of intervals with zero
mutations if you do it for a lower
recombination rate here higher mutation
rate you have more information you
converge extremely quickly to the
distribution so at least if mutation is
fairly fast relative to a combination
you can do calculations with this by
looking at successively more and more
blocks without running into
computational
nightmares
so this is a similar sort of exercise in
which we look at the probability that if
we
have three genomes and we have up to two
recombination events what's the chance
that we get a change of
topology
so we start here
with say one genome has
a p x another genome has B this Locus
qy another genome has
C okay so this is one Locus another
lockers another
lockers and clearly we can have various
topologies three different topologies in
principle we can ask what's the chance
that these three blocks have the same
topology or that the topology changes at
the second site or at the first site or
it changes twice and so on and you can
also then calculate the expected
distance expected sizes of those blocks
conditional on the topologies and these
are the sorts of things you might
imagine trying to use in data if you
were starting to observe uh discordant
or concordant topologies as you move
along the
genome
but go on the question of course which
probably has occurred to those people
who not already asleep um is what you
might actually do with this Machinery in
relation to real data the closest I've
got to it in this talk I hope to get a
bit further but I didn't of course um
the closest I got to it was this issue
of the distribution of lengths of
interval in which there are no mutations
or the distribution of intervals between
Snips essentially and that's something
you can calculate with this Machinery
but the sorts of things I'm thinking
about doing with it is firstable to ask
how robust is this method of assuming a
non-recombining block suppose we have
bit Rec combination how far does that um
you know uh bias or alter your
estimates um another issue is how
accurate is the very popular and
convenient Assumption of the coalescent
as a Markov process along the genome I
mean it's clearly much easier to analyze
data if we can assume that the genealogy
here only depends on the immediately
adjacent genealogy and we treat the
process moving along the genome as a
mark of process that makes things far
simpler and if you do calculations for
discrete Loi 1 2 3 four Loi then you
find that it fits pretty accurately you
can calculate joint distributions of
coalesence times and so on for a number
of low sign and it's you know it's
reasonably close the difficulty though
is having faith that somehow these
errors won't accumulate when we're
analyzing tens of thousands of Loi now
it's not immediately obvious to me that
one can trust this Mark of assumption
maybe it's fine maybe it's not but it
would be nice to use this kind of more
analytic approach to test the accuracy
robustness of the more approximate
methods which we're going to have to use
for larger data sets Okay thank
you following up on the at the beginning
and the question at the beginning about
how to incorporate for example
demography or like so I mean if we if we
thought about a non-re combining region
all the recombination terms would cancel
out but how would you integrate like
even even with that like into this this
um generating function how would you
incorporate like a bottleneck okay yeah
yeah so well it's probably easier to
explain the population splitting
argument but it's basically the same for
a bottleneck so you can easily put into
this model anything that has a uniform
rate so let's suppose we say instead of
that there was a split in the population
at some time definite time in the past
we say well there's a certain rate at
which the population splits in other
words we don't know when the split
occurred and we have some prior if you
like um with an exponential distribution
of the time when the split occurred so
actually it's not clear to me that isn't
any more reasonable or unreasonable than
assuming a fixed time it's you know it's
another model so we can then use the
recursion and we have a formula for the
generating function which involves this
rate of splitting but if you think about
it that generating function is actually
the llast transform of the time at which
the split occurred and if you just take
an inverse transform with respect to
just that one variable able which
actually is not that hard to do
typically um then you can find the
actual I mean you tell mathematic do you
inverse plus transform you put the
generation function in and it does it
I'm not I could do it anyway um so so
then you get a
probability of seeing the observed
mutational configuration or whatever
given that there was a split in the
population at some time in the past and
you can do do the same thing for a
bottleneck you can say well we actually
do the calculation assuming that there
was a bottleneck at some time which is
distributed exponentially there's a rate
at which bottoms occur and but once you
have that you can then easily convert it
into a probability or likelihood
actually for the model given a certain
definite time for the bottl okay so so I
mean it's just a a little trick the
basic idea is that we can deal with more
or less arbitrary I think structured
population models
okay can you tell how the computation
scales with the number of low sight the
number of SES yeah badly badly I mean
the I sort of glossed over this a little
bit and um chose an example with a
fairly small number of sites low sight
Etc or blocks basically the generating
function is a big rational function with
terms which correspond to different
paths through the ancestral
accommodation graph and so the size of
this expression is going to depend on
the total number of paths through the
graph which blows up very very quickly
so in practice where limited we can May
with all sorts of trickery get up to six
genomes um for a structured population
model and a single Locker so we can get
up to maybe four five six blocks in a
single population this kind of thing um
actually it seems that the limiting
factor is often not calculating with
generating function you can press the
button and after a few minutes of
laboring the machine grown and produces
this generating function it's there it's
got all the information you want but
then if you try and calculate anything
from that like the probability of seeing
this particular mutational configuration
You' got to differentiate this big
function with you know a million
terms 10 times and then then it really
it really goes bad so um so it's
slightly frustrating you can produce
this magic function that has all the
information you want about the set of
genealogies but inspecting it and
tabulating the probabilities of all
possible mutational configuration that
actually takes much longer
okay
than